ausländische
[Musik]
willkommen zum aktiven Live-Stream Nummer
50.0
es ist der 17. Oktober 2022 und wir
beginnen die Serie über Interozeption als
Modellierung von Allostase als Kontrolle
willkommen beim aktiven Inferenzinstitut
Wir sind ein partizipatives Online-
Institut, das Lernen und Lernen kommuniziert
Das Üben von angewandter aktiver
Inferenz wird in einem Archiv-Live-Stream aufgezeichnet.
Geben Sie uns also bitte
Feedback, damit wir unsere Arbeit verbessern können.
Alle Hintergründe und Perspektiven sind
willkommen. Wir werden heute in 50.0 gute Video-
Etiketten für Live-Streams
befolgen  Das Papier Interception as
Modeling Allostasis as Control
Die Autoren sind Eli Synesh Jordan
Therialt Dana Brooks John Wilheim Von
DeMint Lisa Feldman Barrett und Karens
Quigley.
Es ist ein Papier, das
im Januar 2022 in der Zeitschrift Biologische Psychologie veröffentlicht wurde,
und dies ist nur eine Einführung und ein
Kontext  Video als Dean hier und ich
arbeite diese Arbeit durch und bespreche einige
verwandte Themen, die
wir haben  Wir werden einige große
Fragen, die grundlegenden Ziele und den abstrakten
Fahrplan des Papiers durchgehen, dann auf das
Papier eingehen, einige Schlüsselpunkte,
Bilder und Themen ansprechen und uns dann in erster Linie
darauf freuen, es mit
Autoren oder anderen, die möchten, zu diskutieren  Ich
bin in den kommenden Wochen in
Ordnung, also bin ich Daniel, ich bin ein Forscher
in Kalifornien, und
das Papier wurde durch dezentrale
positive Abstimmung ausgewählt.
Es hat Spaß gemacht, es zu lesen, und es bringt einige
neue Themen in unser Aufmerksamkeitsregime,
also schaue ich  Weiterleiten und ich gebe
an Dean weiter.
Danke, Charlie. Ich bin Dean. Ich bin hier in
Calgary.
Ich denke, was ist interessant an jedem
Papier, das an scheinbar
diskreten
Dingen zieht und einige in die Nähe bringt und
sie verwickelt und sie dann
wieder auseinander zieht  und versucht zu sehen,
was passiert, wenn Dinge kombiniert werden, ist
immer etwas, an dem ich immer interessiert bin,
dass es tatsächlich der
Titel davon war und die Tatsache, dass
sie Allostase und
Tereszeption zusammenbrachten und was sie tun  Das
war der Grund, warum ich ein
wenig Zeit damit verbracht habe, und
ich bin wirklich sehr daran interessiert zu hören, was die
Autoren zu sagen haben, nachdem sie
diese Idee
richtig umgesetzt haben. Wie würden Sie die große
Frage
gut beschreiben?  Ich denke, der Fokus liegt hier
darauf, was passiert und was wir
über Controller-Anforderungen sagen können, die erforderlich sind
, um physiologische Aufgaben mit unterschiedlichem Komplexitätsgrad auszuführen.
Ich war mir nie wirklich sicher, wie die
Spezifität verschiedener Ergebnisse und
Verhaltensweisen insgesamt aussieht, aber  Ich denke,
eines der Dinge, die wir sagen können, ist, ob
es eine prädiktive Komponente
und eine Feedback-Komponente gibt
und sie sich auf zwei bestimmte
Arten davon konzentrieren,
ähm, es ist vielleicht interessant, mit welcher Art von
Allgemeingültigkeit wir davonkommen können,
ähm, weißt du nicht  irgendwie nicht
im Unkraut verloren gehen, das passierte
hier und dann das, was dort passierte, aber
nur auf dieser allgemeinen Ebene, was
für Dinge, wenn diese beiden
Dinge zusammengefügt werden
ähm, sollten wir sagen, dass ein bestimmtes Muster oder eine
Gemeinsamkeit
nett ist, ich stimme zu, ich würde es in die
Kategorie der Frage einordnen, wie ein bestimmtes
systemunabhängiges oder modalitätsunabhängiges Phänomen wie
Allostase, das antizipierende Veränderungen
in der Physiologie ist und mit einer Domäne
oder einem Anwendungsfall wie Interzeption verbunden ist  und es
scheint, als wären viele der Modelle, die
wir untersucht haben, visuell,
konzeptionell oder symbolisch gewesen,
und die abfangende Modalität ist
immer wieder in Diskussionen aufgetaucht, und daher ist
dies eine coole Gelegenheit, sich
einige Formalismen für das Abfangen
anzusehen  das
zuvor beschriebene Papier nur einige der
Highlights, die von den
Autoren auf der
Publikationsseite geschrieben wurden
Interzeption ermöglicht es dem Gehirn,
die bevorstehenden Stoffwechselbedürfnisse des Körpers
vorherzusehen Interzeption liefert Leistungsmetriken
für die viszerale motorische Regulation
wir verbinden Kontrolltheorie mit
Entscheidungsfindung und motorischer Kontrolle  des Körpers
modellieren wir allostatische Kontrolle als optimale
Kontrolle mit der Zeit variieren  Als
Referenzsignal sprechen sie über einige
Einschränkungen früherer Modelle und einige
einzigartige Aspekte dessen, was ihr Modell tut,
und die Art und Weise, wie sie das Apik-Modell formulieren.
Nein, ich denke, ihre Ziele sind
einfach, in
Ordnung, also haben Dean und ich
nachgedacht  von uns selbst
in Bezug auf Schadensregulierer, Gutachter,
Prüfer und Ermittler,
als wir
eine ganze Handvoll wirklich
wichtiger und herausragender
Argumente aus diesem relativ
langen
und technisch ausgefeilten
Papier herausgezogen und eine Reihe von Ansprüchen herausgezogen haben,
die geschrieben wurden, um die Punkte zu verbinden und
festzulegen  Einige der relevanten uh-
Interpretationen für die Formalismen
möchten Sie einen von ihnen hervorheben oder
es ist in Ordnung, sie nur für jeden zu haben, der davon
absehen möchte,
aber ich werde dies hier sagen,
es gibt eine, denke ich, eine Parallele, die versucht wird,
gezogen zu werden  hier zwischen
prädiktiver
prädiktiver uh Verarbeitung nein, ich sage nicht
, dass prädiktive Verarbeitung, sondern
Verarbeitung als ein prädiktives Gerät
und Gefühle
und Kontrolle und Feedback und ich denke,
es gibt viele Behauptungen, die aufgestellt werden können,
aber das ist ein wirklich
sehr, sehr nuancierter und auch ein sehr, sehr
komplexer Raum, in dem man spielen kann, und daher kann ich
verstehen,
warum es viele, viele gibt  Behauptungen
ähm noch einmal, ob oder wie weit diese
Behauptungen halten können, bevor sie zusammenbrechen,
wird eine interessante Sache sein, mit den Autoren zu sprechen.
Ja, gut gesagt, es ist ein sehr verflochtener
Bereich
Ich habe viele Haare, also ist es
schwierig für mich in
Ordnung,
abstrakt,
okay, ich lese die ersten drei vor.
Das Gehirn reguliert den Körper, indem es
seine Bedürfnisse antizipiert und versucht,
sie zu erfüllen, bevor sie entstehen. Ein Prozess
namens Allostase
Allostase erfordert ein Modell des
Veränderung der sensorischen Bedingungen im
Körper ein Prozess, der als Interzeption bezeichnet wird. In
diesem Artikel untersuchen wir, wie Interozeption
ein Leistungsfeedback für die Allostase liefern kann.
Wir schlagen vor, die Allostase in te zu untersuchen  rms
of Control Theory Überprüfung von Kontrolltheorien
Anwendungen auf verwandte Themen
in der Physiologie Motorkontrolle und Entscheidungsfindung
Wir synthetisieren diese, indem wir sie mit
den wichtigen Eigenschaften der
outostatischen Regulation als Kontrollproblem in Beziehung setzen. Dann
skizzieren wir einen normalen Formalismus dafür, wie das
Gehirn allostatische Kontrolle durchführen könnte
die Eingeweide durch Analogie zweier skelettaler
motorischer Kontrolle einschließlich einer mathematischen
Sichtweise und wie die Schnittmenge als
Leistungsrückmeldung für die Allostase fungiert
schließlich schlagen wir Wege vor, um die
Implikationen unserer Hypothese zu testen
Okay auf das Roadmap-
Papier beginnt mit der Einführung in die
Funktion des Gehirns im Körper
und dann  stellt einige der wichtigsten
Säulen oder Grundlagen ihrer
Synthese und Interpretation vor, nämlich
die
Interzeptionskontrolltheorie als Ansatz zur
Vereinheitlichung der Entscheidungsfindung in der Physiologie, Motorkontrolle
und Allostase als
Bahnverfolgung, stochastische optimale Kontrolle.
Der fünfte Abschnitt ist eine Diskussion, und
dann gibt es einen Anhang B und  C
ein  Und in ihren Worten verbinden vier Abschnitte in diesem
Aufsatz Interzeption mit Allostase.
Abschnitt zwei legt fest, wie
Interozeption dem Gehirn ermöglicht
, die physiologische Leistungsfähigkeit
des Körpers im gegenwärtigen Moment
einzuschätzen, was genau das ist, was es wissen muss,
um Handlungen zu bewerten und zu verfeinern.
Abschnitt 3 führt Kontrolle ein  Theorie
Abschnitt 4 wendet die Prinzipien der
Kontrolltheorie an, um ein neuartiges Formatmodell abzuleiten,
wie das Gehirn
die Erwünschtheit physiologischer
Trajektorien abschätzen und prospektive
regulatorische Entscheidungen treffen könnte. Abschnitt 5 schließlich
fasst die vorherigen drei Abschnitte zusammen
, um die direkten Implikationen
des vorgeschlagenen Formalismus zu untersuchen. Anhang a
enthält ein Glossar mit Begriffen, aber dies wurde
nach oben verschoben und ist kein Anhang mehr,
daher gibt es keinen Anhang. Ein
Anhang B1 enthält mathematische
Details zu Abschnitt 3, und
Anhang C1 enthält mathematische
Details zu Abschnitt 4.
Die Schlüsselwörter waren Interception
Allostasis und Predictive Processing
We  'gehen
In diesem Punkt Null viel über Abfangen und Allostase zu sprechen, aber sicherlich
in den kommenden Diskussionen und für die
vorausschauende Verarbeitung
ist Livestream Nummer 43 mit Maria ein guter aktueller Stream.
Okay, auch nur als Referenz
Um sie zu scannen, wenn Sie möchten,
gibt es eine Nomenklaturtabelle
mit der Definition vieler Wörter, also
hier sind die ersten Nomenklaturbegriffe 1
bis 25.
Und dann ist hier die zweite Hälfte der
Nomenklatur 26 bis 49.
Sortieren Sie sie alphabetisch nach
allem, was der Nomenklatur hinzugefügt werden kann
zu sagen, dass
es gut ist, dass sie es bereitgestellt haben und
es in den kommenden Abschnitten verwendet wird. Nun,
ich finde es interessant, dass Sie
darauf hingewiesen haben, dass sie
die Definitionen nach vorne gezogen haben, und dann,
wenn Sie sich die Formalismen ansehen, und so denke ich
Vom Standpunkt dessen,
was sie damit aussagen wollen, erfordert
dieses Geflecht,
dass wir zumindest einen
gesunden Menschenverstand darüber bekommen, was die Dinge
vorher bedeuten  wir fangen an zu
versuchen, auseinander zu ziehen, was sie gleich sind,
also ja, ich irgendwie so ähnlich
gut gesagt
alles klar Abschnitt eins Einführung in die
Funktionen des Gehirns im Körper
okay,
es gibt einen eindrucksvollen Anfang für dieses
Papier,
dann spielen wir ein einfaches
Völkerballspiel  erfordert Ihr Gehirn,
um die Systeme Ihres Körpers kontinuierlich zu koordinieren,
und dieses Motiv des Völkerballs wird
wieder zurückkehren,
und auf der linken Seite ist eine umarmende
Gesichtsimplementierung eines stabilen Diffusionsalgorithmus
und während wir die Folien erstellten, beschäftigten wir
uns mit aktiven Schlussfolgerungen mit
einigen dieser
bildgenerierenden Angebote und erlaubten dem,
was gut zu tun.
Ich denke, es ist wirklich interessant,
dass das, was der Generator sagte
, das Ergebnis eines
koordinierten
ähm,
was ist, wäre  Wort Ich suche nach einer
Verstrickung dieser dieser Eingabeaufforderungen
, habe aber nichts darüber gesprochen, welche
Strategie jeder hat  Diese
ähm Silhouetten verwenden jetzt
und ich denke, dass es ein implizites
Gefühl gibt, dass es auch eine Strategie gibt,
also wieder, wenn Sie einige
dieser wirklich interessanten Dinge zusammenbringen,
ähm, ich denke, es hängt davon ab, wie tief Sie
gehen wollen  Sie möchten
den Raum dimensionieren,
also was ist das genau dort? Ja, das ist
die gleiche Aufforderung. Das war nur eine weitere
Nächstes Schlüsselwort Sie können es versuchen,
wenn Sie nur die Definition hier lesen können,
aber geben Sie einfach Ihre eigene
Meinung ab, was Abfangen ist. Nun, ich denke, am Ende des
Tages gibt es eine gewisse Menge
an Signalisierung, die
uns bewusst wird  Manchmal kategorisieren junge Leute
oder alle Leute
sie alle irgendwie unter dem Dach der Gefühle
und ähm,
ich habe das von Tots On Target geholt, nur
weil ich immer in t gearbeitet habe
Wie können wir das so einfach
wie möglich halten? Wenn Sie also diese
Signale erhalten, stammen diese sensorischen Signale
aus dem Inneren des Körpers. Dies sind die
Gefühle, die Sie bekommen, und ähm, ob
Sie sie mit der Welt außerhalb von Ihnen verbinden oder nicht
Haut oder deine Ränder
ähm, manchmal tust du es, manchmal wachst du nicht auf,
du wachst einfach mit Bauchschmerzen auf, richtig,
also was bedeutet das heute
? Schön,
ich würde sagen, ein wenig eng gefasstes
Abfangen bezieht sich auf einige
Beobachtungen und Schlussfolgerungen zu verborgenen
Zuständen
mit einem Referenten  das ist im Tarot im
Inneren des Körpers im Gegensatz zum X-Tarot
außerhalb des Körpers, aber es gibt wahrscheinlich
auch viel wie Unschärfe und was
die Netzhaut wirklich tut, ist, dass sie
Rückschlüsse auf sich selbst zieht, und wo macht sie
tatsächlich Rückschlüsse auf die Struktur der Außenwelt
?  Richtig abfangende
interne Modelle Sie haben einige Bilder hinzugefügt, also
was sind sie,
also werde ich das nur ganz schnell lesen, also
beziehen sich Psychologen auf den internen Mod,
einschließlich Abfangen mit vielen Begriffen und
Ich denke, ich denke, das ist wichtig,
weil es nicht immer
Einigkeit darüber gab, klar zu definieren, was ein
internes Modell ist.
Dinge wie unbewusstes Interesse
scheinen in diesen Schirm zu passen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das
überhaupt bedeutet, äh, und unabhängig davon, wie
es genannt wird, wird angenommen, dass das Gehirn
ein dynamisches Modell seines Körpers in
der Welt konstruiert. In diesem Artikel verwenden wir die Begriffe
Vorhersagesimulation und Konzept und damit
für jemanden mit meinem
tiefgreifenden Forschungshintergrund  in puncto
entführung das signal das interpretiert
das objekt
ähm was ist das modell wie
vermeiden wir wie vermeiden wir eine weitere große
debatte darüber ob das
gegenständlich und inhaltlich gefüllt ist oder
nicht oder gibt es da etwas was
wir
immer von innen spüren
Einmalige Daten kommen auf uns zu und
werden
auf unsere verschiedenen sensorischen Oberflächen gegossen
außen außen außen außen
Ich denke, es gibt ein Stück,
das von außen kommt, ich weiß, wenn die
Temperatur im Raum steigt, aber meine
Temperatur könnte auch steigen,
weil ich eine schlechte Garnele gegessen habe, und es ist
manchmal schwierig herauszufinden,
ob es daran liegt, dass die Hitze
weg ist  oder ob mein Körper
mit einer entzündlichen
Geste reagiert,
ja, das ist ein
netter Punkt, wie manchmal als
Unterschied machende Ursache oder Unterschied
, der einen Unterschied macht, bezeichnet
das Virus im
Vergleich dazu die Dynamik des
Immunsystems
so
interessantes Bild links weiß, dass ich
nicht sagen kann, ob das Bild links
durch das Bild links mit welcher
Geschwindigkeit sich das Bild rechts tatsächlich
die Straße entlang bewegt und  Aus diesem
Grund wollte ich die Mehrdeutigkeit dort
für ein Enterozeptormodell, denn Sie
wissen, dass Demacio viel darüber spricht, was
wir wirklich
beschreiben und pr verfolgen können  Ecise Begriffe und
was etwas mehrdeutig bleibt, und die
Autoren in diesem Artikel sprechen auch ein wenig
über Gott. Ja, wenn der
Referent extern ist, ist es objektiv, dann gibt es
die Möglichkeit für mehrere externe
Perspektiven, sich anzugleichen, nicht einmal zu sagen,
dass das besser ist, sondern nur die Möglichkeit
, während  Wenn das verkörperte Verhalten
Ihres physiologischen Sollwerts für eine
physiologische
Regulierung geändert wird, hat es nicht die gleiche
Gelegenheit zur externen Ausrichtung,
zum Besseren und zum Schlechteren,
und fast immer mit Schwierigkeiten bei der
Kommunikation oder manchmal auch bei der Messung in
Laborumgebungen und der Zitatkontrolle.
So  Mit Autoren darüber zu sprechen und warum
sie diese Modalität studieren,
wird interessant sein, da die
rechnerischen oder
systemunabhängigen Phänomene, die
sie versuchen werden,
mit Alice zu integrieren, im Schnittpunkt
Allostase sind. Sie definieren diesen Begriff als
Allostase, um es vorwegzunehmen  sich ändernde
Bedürfnisse Prioritäten bewerten und
die Organisation vorbereiten  sm, um sie zu befriedigen, bevor sie
zu Fehlern führen, ein Prozess namens
Allostase. Sagen wir also einfach, dass
Sie ein allostatisches Modell der
Temperatur im Raum haben
und sich die Körperkerntemperatur nicht
ändert, also kann man zurückblicken und sagen, dass
es nicht so ist  ändern, weil erwartet wurde, dass
es sich ändert,
und jemand wird nur sagen, woher
weißt du, dass es damals funktioniert hat, weil es
die Körpertemperatur nicht erhöht
hat?  wir reden immer davon,
was hier das Minimum ist, was wir hier mindestens
brauchen, um das zu können.
Ich finde das wirklich nicht wirklich
interessant,
warum drei und
nicht vier oder fünf es
in kleinere Scheiben aufteilen, das ist
wieder so eine  Fragen, die ich
gerne mit den Autoren über alle richtigen aktiven Inferenzen sprechen könnte, die
sie geschrieben haben,
bevor
wir in die formalen Modellierungsdetails
unten eintauchen, auf die wir später
in der Arbeit
eingehen werden, für die es hilfreich sein könnte  Vergleichen und
kontrastieren Sie den Ansatz hier
apic mit der aktiven Inferenz des prominenten Modellierungsframeworks,
und wir werden
auf einige dieser Details zurückkommen, und ich bin mir
sicher, dass wir viel darüber diskutiert haben, aber
Sie haben in unserer Vorbereitung einen wirklich interessanten Punkt
darüber angesprochen, wie  Sie
behandeln ihr Modell nicht als
Downstream oder als Folge einer
Verpflichtung zu einer bestimmten Physik
, wie wir oft über das Prinzip der freien Energie hören, im
Grunde Mechanik
, sondern sie behandeln
das
Modell als eine Konstruktion erster Ordnung,
alles, was Sie hinzufügen möchten  Das, weil
ich dachte, das war wirklich so, als würde ich mir helfen, einen
Rahmen zu schaffen, worum es in dem Papier ging.
Ja, das ist der Street-Teil. Ich denke, dass das
Arbeitsbulletin im Gegensatz zu den meisten
Modellen für aktives Interesse in der Literatur das
Material unten eine unbestimmte
Zeit oder eine unendliche
Horizontsteuerungseinstellung für interessant hält weil  Das macht es
wirklich sehr deutlich zwischen dem, worüber sie
sprechen, und dem, was wir oft in
vielen Darstellungen sehen, nämlich t0
T1 bis T
was auch immer
in Bezug auf die Fähigkeit, herauszufinden,
was sequentiell vor sich geht, also in
Ordnung,
dieser Abschnitt in der Einführung spricht
über einige Probleme mit anderen Modellen, in denen
sie darüber sprechen, wie bestehende Modelle des
Abfangens entweder
Allostase als prospektive
Entscheidung formuliert haben.  Problem zu machen,
ohne zu berücksichtigen, wie diese
Entscheidungen umgesetzt werden, was eine Reihe
unterschiedlicher Interpretationen hat, aber möglicherweise zum
Beispiel die Aufzählung von
Richtlinien und dann die Auswahl aus
Richtlinien
oder als Motorsteuerungsproblem erfordert, ohne zu
berücksichtigen, woher motorische Befehle aus
einem anderen Problem stammen, das sie mit anderen haben
Modelle, anstatt die metabolische
Effizienz als Ziel zu behandeln, diskutieren sie
Homöostase, die Regulierung von
Körpervariablen, um Sollwerte mit fester Fehlertoleranz zu fixieren,
also wird dies wirklich ein cooles
Thema, das
eher darin besteht, den Sollwert und die
Variabilität als
das Ergebnis zu sehen  aufgrund eines
anderen Prozesses, der zu einem
Attra führt  Menge oder Punkt mit einem festen
Sollwert und einer empirischen
Fehlertoleranz sowie vielleicht einigen Punkten ohne
Wiederkehr und so weiter zu betrachten,
aber all diese Ergebnisse als die
Verwirklichung eines dynamischen Systems zu sehen, das
eigentlich keinen Sollwert verfolgt, sondern
eher  verfolgt eine Steigung in einem Diagramm, das
wir untersuchen werden, und das wie eine Zone
maximaler Kontrollierbarkeit
und eine Verringerung der Überraschung um die
Zone maximaler Kontrollierbarkeit im
Laufe der
Evolutionszeit mit dieser Art von Überlebensvariable
und einigen anderen Punkten in Verbindung gebracht wird, okay alles andere
Nun, es ist Beziehung Beziehung
Beziehung und dann sagen sie, dass dieses
Papier darauf abzielt, diese Lücke zu füllen.
Ich denke, Beziehung bedeutet nicht
unbedingt, dass die
Dinge in Bezug auf was auch immer die Lücke ist, geschlossen
werden müssen, indem ich etwas fülle, denke ich,
die Tatsache, dass sie  Wenn wir über Targeting sprechen,
denke ich über die Tatsache, dass sie
Beziehungen als eine
Art Schlüsselrolle in dem sehen, was ihrer Meinung nach
hier passiert,
ähm bedeutet das  dass sie vielleicht die Lücke
ähm fortsetzen. Ich meine, sie
fügen hier Sachen ein, damit wir darüber
nachdenken und nachdenken können, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob wir tatsächlich eine Lücke füllen, wo
wir nur irgendwie verstehen, was darin ist
Leerzeichen
rechter
Abschnitt zwei, also am Anfang von
Abschnitt zwei die oberen
Absätze, die den
Körper modellieren und seine Effizienz schätzen, und dann
der Abschnitt „below the fold“,
Abschnitt 2.5, die Zusammenfassung, also sowohl
Pre- als auch Post-2
die wichtigsten Punkte in diesem Papier
alles, was zu dieser speziellen Folie hinzugefügt werden kann
, oder wir gehen einfach zu den Abschnitten mit dem
Stern ganz unten, dort
möchten die Leute vielleicht etwas darüber lesen,
weil ich denke, dass das und das heißt
, dass das umstritten ist, aber  Ich denke, es
ist interessant, ja,
ähm, dass die Bewegung in Richtung des
Reaktionsbereichs einer
Kapazitätskurve möglicherweise die
Notwendigkeit einer dedizierten neuronalen Schaltung oder eines Moduls beseitigen könnte,
das die speziell berechnet
Verhaltenskonstrukte der Belohnung von Kosten,
also was bedeutet es
, zu einem
nicht-belohnungszentrierten
Verständnis der Physiologie
überzugehen oder Belohnung neu zu interpretieren?
von viszeralen
sensorischen Variablen interzeptiv
diejenigen, die Mengen von
Ressourcen darstellen regulierte Ressourcen und diejenigen,
die Raten darstellen, mit denen
Prozesse agieren kontrollierte Prozesse
regulierte Ressourcen werden im
Laufe der Zeit relativ stabil gehalten Beispiele
hierfür sind Blutzucker und Körperkerntemperatur
Um eine
erschöpfbare Ressource zu sein, ist
die regulierte Ressource so etwas wie
die begrenzte Variable in einer Physiologie in
einem Homöostase-Kontext, es ist nicht
notwendigerweise
kann sich nicht sofort ändern,
also ich  Ich denke, es wird
interessant sein zu fragen,
was verschiedene regulierte
Ressourcen verschiedener Modalitäten sind
und welche kontrollierten
Prozesse die Geschwindigkeiten sind, mit denen physiologische
Prozesse ablaufen. In diesem Fall wäre
es wie die Art der Input-Output-
Beziehungen von Blutzucker.
Okay, ja, wir reden nur  Darüber haben wir
kürzlich gesprochen, was ist der
Unterschied zwischen gripper und gript und
kann beides auf einmal existieren?
2.2 zurück zum DodgeBall-Beispiel Die
Herzfrequenz und der Blutdruck
müssen während des Aerobic-Trainings steigen, wie
im DodgeBall-Beispiel angegeben,
also muss es so sein
Um mit dem Training zu beginnen und
das Training im Ruhezustand fortzusetzen, ist eine gewisse physiologische Anpassung
erforderlich. Der Barorezeptor
, der Druckrezeptor-Herzfrequenzreflex,
würde normalerweise einem
Anstieg des Blutdrucks entgegenwirken, indem er den Herzschlag verlangsamt.
Bei Anstrengung
müssen jedoch sowohl Ihr Blutdruck als auch Ihre Herzfrequenz
steigen, um dies zu unterstützen  benötigte
Erhöhung des Blutflusses, die von Ihrem Ex benötigt wird
Muskelaufbau
und so gibt es eine Diskussion darüber, wie
diese Art der Modulation von
Reflexen die Verschiebung einer ganzen Funktion ermöglicht,
die eine Änderung des Blutdrucks mit einer
Änderung Ihrer Herzfrequenz in Beziehung setzt,
also beschreibt dies wie ein dynamischer
Systemansatz und ein physiologisches Modell
dafür  wie die kausale oder korrelative
Struktur verschiedener physiologischer
Variablen ziemlich allgemein modelliert werden kann,
aber es wird
noch spezifischer,
ja, ein bisschen Kovariation
und äh
und Physiologie und los geht's,
okay 2.2 Vorhersage und Modellierung der
Bereiche von regulierten und kontrollierten
Prozessen dies  beschreibt einige der
Parameter
der Kurve
die Schwellen- und Sättigungspunkte,
die teilweise abgeleitet werden Definieren Sie Kurven,
die von Funktionen abgeleitet sind,
die Physiologen üblicherweise verwenden,
um die Verbindung zwischen
Störungen und regulatorischen Reaktionen zu modellieren, und
nennen sie normalerweise Reaktionskurven oder
Übertragungsfunktionen
und dann den Begriff Kapazität  Kurven
werden zur Hervorhebung verwendet  Die Tatsache, dass sich
solche Kurven zwar jederzeit im Laufe der Zeit verschieben können,
sie jedoch die
aktuelle Bandbreite der begrenzten regulatorischen
Ressourcen darstellen, die einem Organismus zur Verfügung stehen,
so dass man sich wie eine Finanzkapazitätskurve vorstellen kann, einen
Markt an einem bestimmten Punkt wie etwa
die Tiefe aufrechtzuerhalten
Aber
analog
und dann erfordert diese ähm-
Idee, zu modellieren, wie ein System
auf Störungen
reagiert, nicht unbedingt das Modellieren des
internen Modells dieses Systems, sondern wenn Sie
ein besseres generatives Modell des
gestörten Systems erstellen als die besseren
Experimente und je weiter Sie können  uh,
eine Art Störung des
Systems, die es Ihnen ermöglicht, sich Ihrem
System ohne eine starke Hypothese über
seine
Struktur zu nähern. Die Kapazitätskurve in Abbildung zwei hat den Punkt
oder in Abbildung eins die mathematische
Form, und dann wird Abbildung eins
neben Gleichung eins gezeigt
die Parameter sind  definierte die Funktion
y ist uh, indem man U mu K als R Big B
annimmt und diese zu einer Gleichung in
der Abbildung eins kombiniert  Die x-Achse zeigt
den Blutdruck
und die y-Achse zeigt den
Basislinienaktivierungsprozentsatz des
Reflexes, der diese physiologische
Variable moduliert, also bei 100, was der
Zielblutdruck oder eine Art
homöostatischer Sollwert ist, weil
es so ist  scheint
an diesem Punkt ein Attraktor zu sein, bei dem die Baseline-Aktivierung
des Barrel-Reflexes stattfindet,
wenn der Blutdruck ansteigt, dann wird
der Barrel-Reflex bis zu 2x
Thresholding bei 2x-Aktivierung der
Baseline aktiviert und dann, wenn der
Blutdruck den Barrel-Reflex wieder mit
diesem Sigmoid senkt  Symmetrieabnahmen
Das ist ein dynamisches Modell der Regulierung
des Blutdrucks
Gleichungen 2 3 und 4.
Skizzieren Sie die Form eines generativen Modells Ein
Verfahren zur probabilistischen
Vorhersage beobachteter Variablen in Bezug
auf unbeobachtete
Variablen Die aufgeführten Variablen sind unbeobachtete
Variablen, die aus einer A
Priory-Wahrscheinlichkeit abgetastet werden  Verteilung nicht
abhängig von Daten
, also bezieht sich dies auf die Verwendung eines
Generats  ive-Modell und wie diese
Gleichungen es darstellen
Der Vorschlag hier hat eine ungewöhnliche Eigenschaft,
die Gleichungen für X den mittleren arteriellen
Blutdruck und warum die
Fassreflexaktivierung als Prozentsatz der Baseline,
also Abbildung 1 X und Y
oder in Bezug auf die Quantilvariable U
die  Quantilvariable
stellt einheitlich den Zusammenhang zwischen dem
Blutdruck und der Fassreflexaktivierung dar,
unabhängig von Änderungen
des Arbeitspunkts mu
und der Verstärkung K
der Kapazitätskurve
Das ist ein bisschen technischer,
aber sie weisen darauf hin, dass als Merkmal
ihres Modells
hier wieder Abbildung eins etwas größer ist
mit mehr Platz für spätere Diskussionen und
hier ist Abbildung zwei,
die die Kapazitätskurve aus Abbildung
eins in Blau mit einer linearisierten Antwort
in Orange ist
um den Arbeitspunkt herum die blaue
Raute,
so dass
man dies als die maximale positive
Steigung dieser sigmoidalen Kurve erkennen kann
das unter
der Spezifikation,
dass der Reflex dann sigmoidal aktiviert wird
,
je nachdem, ob man sich in
einem nach oben oder nach unten gekrümmten Teil befindet
oder darüber nachdenkt, die
maximale positive Steigung zu
verfolgen, dann diesen Punkt zu verfolgen und
belohnt zu werden  durch Bewegungen in Richtung maximaler
Manövrierfähigkeit und Kontrolle
hätte das Äquivalent eines
homöostatischen Modells, bei dem dies wie ein
Fixpunkt-Attraktor ist,
sodass die Art des Bodens der
Schüssel
in dieser orangefarbenen Linie in der Neigung maximiert wird,
anstatt dass die blaue Raute darin
reduziert wird  Sein Abstand von 100.
Richtig. Ich glaube, wir haben diesen Abschnitt zweimal kopiert, er war so ungewöhnlich, dass wir ihn zweimal kopiert haben. Ja. 2.3 Zurück zum DodgeBall-Beispiel,
und sie werden ihren Anwendungsbereich
über den Barrow-Reflex-Blutdruck hinaus
auf zirkulierende Sauerstoffglukosewerte erweitern
und Kohlendioxid Als
nächstes konzentrieren wir uns auf Blutzucker als
regulierte Ressource mit Glukagon als dem
kontrollierten Prozess, der die Sekretion von ermöglicht
Glukose in das Blut und Insulin
als Kontrollprozess, der die Entfernung von
Glukose aus dem Blut ermöglicht, so dass der Barrel-
Reflex wie ein einzelner Lautstärkeregler
oder eine Triage-Krankenschwester war,
die die einzelne Reaktion verringern oder erhöhen kann. Wenn also eine
physiologische Variable hoch ist, ist es so, als ob
es möglich wäre  sein wie entfernt
Glukoseregulierung hat mehrere Hormone
es wird wie von zwei
verschiedenen Seiten auf etwas andere
Weise gepuffert sein, aber mit vielen der gleichen
Formalismen und Logik
, um ein etwas
anderes und komplexeres physiologisches
System einzuführen.
Okay,
der Abschnitt diskutiert einige Ergebnisse
dass der Blutzuckerspiegel nicht
aktiv an einem biologisch
fest codierten Sollwert gehalten wird, genauso wenig wie die
Herzfrequenz ist, sondern dass Glukagon und Insulin zwei
Hormone sind, die ihre
Wirkung gegenseitig ausgleichen,
um den Blutzucker auf einen Punkt
innerhalb seines Einschwingbereichs zu bringen,
wobei Glukose eindringt  Blut, nachdem
die Person Nahrung und Glukose zu sich genommen hat, dann
Übergang vom Blut in andere
Körper  Gewebe, um ihre Funktion zu unterstützen
irgendetwas hinzuzufügen auf dieser
Folie nicht speziell jetzt warten Sie, bis
wir zum Ende des Abschnitts kommen, die zweiten
beiden Dinge,
also hier ist Abbildung drei, die
sie schreiben. Abbildung drei
zeigt Diagramme der resultierenden
Funktionen dieser Gleichung, auf die sie
angewendet werden  Der Insulinfall,
der als Kapazitätskurve interpretiert werden kann,
ist das orangefarbene Sigmoid für Insulin,
das blaue Sigmoid für Glukagon.
Sie haben unterschiedliche Hormonspiegel auf
verschiedenen x-Achsen, was dem
Glukosespiegel im Blut entspricht, und Sie
sehen also ein bekanntes Verhalten, wenn der Glukosespiegel
hoch ist  dann ist die Insulinsekretion hoch,
was die Absorption von Glukose antreibt,
und wenn die Glukose in diesem Fall
unter 2,5 oder 3 oder so
sinkt, wird Glukagon ausgeschieden, um die Glukose
zu veranlassen, in Ordnung in das Blut zu gelangen,
und so kann man sich vorstellen, dass der
Glukosespiegel oszillieren wird  in diesem Bereich,
aber nicht genau
auf einen Sollwert festgelegt, wobei ein Residuum
minimiert
wird
del
uh in realisierbare Bereiche und Kapazitäten
könnte ein modulares Belohnungssystem vermeiden.
Hier ist ein Argument oder ein Appell an die
Neuroanatomie. Es gibt keine einzelne
Gehirnstelle, die speziell
appetitive oder aversive Verstärkungswerte
kodiert. Es ist nützlich, diskrete
Belohnungs- und Entscheidungssysteme als Domäne
umzugestalten  Die Domäne Allgemeinheit des Abfangens
bietet weitere theoretische Unterstützung für
die Idee, dass wir keine mentalen Module oder Fakultätspsychologiekonzepte benötigen, um
zu verstehen, wie ein Gehirn funktioniert.
Eine mathematisch fundierte und biologisch
plausible Darstellung allostatischer Kontrolle
erfordert kein modulares oder separates
Belohnungssystem in der Zentrale  Nervensystem
und ein bisschen mehr zu diesem Thema Alles, was
hinzugefügt werden kann, kommen
wir nun zu 37.
Okay, die Belohnungen der Kontrolle, also
wollte ich hier zwei Artikel mit
einigen netten Bildern
von beiden Artikeln hervorheben, an denen Tobias Norville beteiligt ist,
und diese Artikel werden in dem Artikel zitiert
in der Diskussion und sie alle zeigen
ziemlich viel Interesse  Ruhefunktionen, um nur
einige dieser Graphen hervorzuheben,
hier sind Bewegungen innerhalb eines Glukose-
und Temperaturraums, also ist die Regulierung
mehrerer physiologischer Variablen
hier unten links die
Integration des Abfangens des homöostatischen
Sollwerts und motorischer Befehle, wie im
Zusammenhang mit der Nahrungssuche,
hier sind einige Bayes'sche
Visualisierungen mit  eine
frühere und spätere Unwahrscheinlichkeit und über diese wechselseitige
Beziehung der Schlussfolgerung und ein früheres
dynamisches Modell die Geschichte von zwei
Dichten und dann die letzte, dies ist ein
weiterer
Ansatz zur Modellierung von Körpertemperatur-
Glukose, der zu dem Begriff führt, den
wir als auf den Grund gehend beschreiben  der
Schüssel,
wo die Form dieser
Serviette entworfen, entwickelt oder ausgewählt werden könnte,
so dass die Murmel die meiste
Zeit in einer bestimmten Zone verbringt, und dies ist
nur eine andere Art, über
diese Art von Attraktorsystemen nachzudenken,
anstatt wie Spuren  oder so weiter
okay irgendetwas hinzuzufügen
gut Ich denke Abschnitt zwei
bestätigt im Grunde, dass, wenn Sie t gehen  Ich
mache irgendeine Art von Vorhersageleistung
, die ein Element der Kontinuität
hat, das von
erkennbaren endlichen Grenzen und auch der
Variabilität innerhalb dieser Grenzen abhängt,
und ich denke, das
spricht irgendwie für die Idee, dass
es ein In gibt  eine Art Zwei-Faktor-Situation,
es gibt Signale, die so aussehen,
und sie haben auf ein paar
Beispiele für den Fassreflex
und das Glucagon-Ding hingewiesen, und
sie haben auch versucht, eine
übermäßige Vereinfachung oder übermäßige Reduzierung zu vermeiden, wie
sie es versuchten
Die Komplexität dieser beiden Beispiele
in Bezug auf das, was sie
aufrechtzuerhalten versuchten, beizubehalten, ist etwas, das
es uns ermöglicht, diese
Kapazitätskurven
zu betrachten  ihrer Zusammenfassungen des
Kapitels stellt dieser
Abschnitt Konzepte aus der
Techniksteuerungstheorie vor und gibt dann einen Überblick über ihre
Anwendungen in den Biowissenschaften  Dazu
gehören Physiologie, Abschnitt 3.1,
Skelettmotorische Bewegung, Abschnitt 3.2, und
Entscheidungsfindung, Abschnitt 3.3, Abschnitt 3.4, wird
zukünftige interzeptive Zustände mit gegenwärtigen Bewegungen verbinden. Um zu
beleuchten, was
die allostatische Regulation
energieeffizienter als die homöostatische Regulation macht, wird
der nächste Abschnitt 4 auf der
in der Physiologie verwendeten Darstellung der Kontrolle aufbauen  um
vorzuschlagen, wie das Abfangen die Allostase unterstützt,
okay, hier werden wir nicht
alles auf der Folie lesen, aber dies ist aus
Abschnitt 3.1 Kontrolltheorie für die
Physiologie ein zuverlässiger, zuverlässiger Körper,
der aus unzuverlässigen Teilen aufgebaut ist
Ja, ich
rufe einfach nach einem Controller, der
eine gute Leistung erbringen soll. Er muss eine
Art Kopie oder Spiegel des erwarteten Verhaltens der Anlage enthalten, das
als internes Modell bezeichnet wird.
Steuerungstheoretiker nennen dies „Assist the
Driven System to Plant“ und seine gewünschte
Flugbahn als Referenz  Flugbahn
und es gibt einige interessante Diskussionen
über diese Art von Ähm
Faden der Steuerungstheorie
Abbildung vier
Also ist Abbildung vier ein funktionales
Blockdiagramm eines modellbasierten Steuerungssystems.
Die Anlage in Orange ist das Objekt oder
System, dessen Bewegung oder anderes Verhalten
gesteuert wird.
Der Controller lila sendet Signale
und
signalisiert dem Zustandsschätzer in Gelb die erwarteten Ergebnisvorhersagen mit einem
durchgehenden gelben Pfeil
usw. Die Leute können
den Rest
für diese Zahlen lesen, Daniel, wenn wir
weiter unten in den Folien sind, warum lese ich nicht
, und dann können Sie den Cursor ausführen
über die verschiedenen Teile des Modells, damit die
Leute irgendwie sehen und in Echtzeit sehen können,
wie sich die beiden Dinge ausrichten, klingt
gut, wir werden das für die zukünftigen tun,
und dies
wird unsere früheren Diskussionen im Live-
Stream widerrufen oder daran erinnern  23 geschickte Leistung und
Interaktionismus und Instruktionismus und
wie man über motorische Pflanzen nachdenkt und so
weiter richtiger
Abschnitt 3.2 den Körper bewegen die
Referenzkontrollhypothese so die
Referenzkontrollhypothese Die
bereitgestellten Zitate beziehen sich auf Feldman 2015
und Latash 2021,
und die
Referenzkontrollhypothese beschreibt das Skelettmotorsystem in
Form einer Hierarchie von Controllern, wobei Controller auf
höherer Ebene im Gehirn
Referenzbahnen zu
den Reflexen auf niedrigerer Ebene im
Rückenmark vorschreiben diese  Reflexe vergleichen dann die
tatsächliche Länge des Muskels, wie sie
von afferenten Propriozeptor-Neuronen signalisiert wird
, mit der vom Gehirn gesendeten Referenzlänge
und ziehen den Muskel zusammen, um die
beiden in Übereinstimmung zu bringen. Hier ist also der
obere Teil des Inhaltsverzeichnisses von
Feldmans Buch von 2015  Referentenkontrolle von
Handlung und Wahrnehmung und das Papier von
Latash in der Physik des Lebens Rückblick 2021
mit einigen Grafiken zu dieser Art von
Ansatz aus dem
Ausland.
Sie können mit dieser Folie über die
reale Welt beginnen.
Okay, ich möchte nur auf ein paar Dinge hinweisen,
die die Autoren sagen  weil sie
nicht der Art von Überanpassung beschuldigt werden wollen,
beginnen Sie hier mit Ihrer motorischen Kontrolle  Experiment ist
nur begrenzte Überschneidung mit der tatsächlichen
Struktur der Motorsteuerung, daher
nur begrenzte Überschneidung Experiment zum
Greifverhalten beinhaltet einen
Experimentator, der den Teilnehmern die Greifaufgabe vorschreibt Das
Gehirn der Teilnehmer funktioniert nicht speziell,
um Anweisungen eines Experimentators zu befolgen,
sondern vielmehr, um ihren eigenen Körper zu regulieren
Die eigentliche Organisation des zentralen
Nervensystems erfolgt besser mit einem
Blick von innen nach außen auf die motorischen
Funktionen des Körpers, d. h. die
somatosomatomotorischen Bahnen, die die Regulierung des Körpers regulieren,
z. B. im Spiel mit Dr.
Wert, wenn Sie unerwartet auf einen harten
oder scharfen Block treten oder  Objekt spießt man sich normalerweise
nicht absichtlich auf, wer darauf
getreten ist, also wollte
ich jetzt einfach meinen Fuß durchbohren,
weil ich mich vielleicht immer noch auf die
Stabilisierung meiner Körperhaltung konzentriere, die Schwerkraft mit Windung
und Schmerzen, die Sie abfangen
und die ungeplante Störung von jedem spüren
Gewebeschäden erfordern, dass Sie eine
Entscheidung darüber treffen, was als nächste Entschuldigung zu tun ist
Sich selbst den Fuß pflegen oder
diesen Schmerz durchspielen
Ich denke, die Tatsache, dass sie versuchen, das
, was sie sagen, einzuschränken, ist das Ausmaß,
in dem das
Zielstück davon als eine gute Sache bezeichnet werden kann,
weil ich denke, dass es eine gibt  einige
Bereiche
herum,
also was ist in dieser Beziehung zwischen
einem Befehlssystem oder einem Kontrollsystem und
einem Anforderungssystem, wo Dinge getan werden,
wie wenn Ihr
Körper anfängt, an leichter Unterkühlung zu leiden,
und Sie wissen, dass die Leute wissen, dass
Ihr Gehirn nicht mehr richtig funktioniert
ähm, wie unterscheidest du zum Beispiel zwischen
ähm, ich bekomme Slurpee-Kopfschmerzen
und du legst den Slurpee weg und hörst auf, ihn zu
trinken, weil du weißt, dass das
die Wirkung ist, und dass du deine Gliedmaßen hast, von
denen du weißt, dass sie an
diesem Punkt oder an diesem Punkt erfroren sind  Hoffentlich nicht für
uns, Knopf Bewege dich weiter, damit du
dich nicht aufhältst, du vermeidest es, aufzuhören, dich
alle zusammen zu bewegen, was im
Wesentlichen der Tod ist, also haben wir hier eine
Frage, ob
ähm w oder nicht  Ohne auf das Argument einzugehen,
weil es ziemlich offensichtlich ist, wenn Ihr
Gehirn tot ist, sind Sie tot, aber wenn Ihre
Hände tot sind oder Sie noch
am Leben sind, diese klare Unterscheidung zwischen einer
Konsequenz des Kommandozentrums und einer
Konsequenz des Nachfragezentrums, was bedeutet das
in Begriffen  Okay, es gibt Dinge, die
passieren, die Sie automatisch
tun, um sich in einigen
der kritischsten Situationen am Leben zu erhalten, und es ist
nicht so, als hätte Ihre Ihre
Ihre Hand das Gehirn, und doch kann es sein, dass Sie
sich einfach nur über eine reflexive Sache hinaus bewegen
in der Lage, Sie
lange genug am Leben zu erhalten, bis jemand
zu Ihrer Rettung kommt, zum Beispiel als a,
also weiß ich nicht, ob das verwirrend ist oder
nicht, aber ich denke, dass es eine
Versöhnung gibt, aber das geht zwischen
Befehl und Forderung und vielleicht etwas
Kontrolle  ist die Fähigkeit,
befohlene Zeiten aufzugeben, damit eine neue,
neue Reaktion übernimmt und Sie
am Leben erhält, und Sie wissen möglicherweise nicht unbedingt
, wie man das von einer
Kommandozentrale aus macht, also wir.  Ich muss mit den
Autoren darüber sprechen, denn das sind
Fragen, die ich habe, weil ich ein
bisschen physiologischen Hintergrund habe, also
wundere ich mich über diese Extremsituationen, in
Ordnung,
Abschnitt 33, Entscheidungen treffen, Konstruktion
zukünftiger Referenzbahnen,
sie verwenden das Wort Forderungen, also
wir.  Ich werde später darüber sprechen, ja, weitere
Zitate von drei drei für diejenigen,
die Screenshots
über Ergonomie machen möchten, die
auch in Anhang B angesprochen wird, auf die wir
uns nicht konzentrieren werden.
Okay, Sie können Abbildung fünf lesen, und ich
werde die Maus verwenden  äh, also ein funktionales
Blockdiagramm für ein Experiment Experimentelle
Psychologe aufgabenorientierte Ansicht der
Motorsteuerung Das Diagramm zeigt
hier
auf konzeptioneller Ebene eine formale Logikstruktur Die Kästchen und
Pfeile bilden im Gegensatz zu Abbildung 4 nicht die Anatomie
des Gehirns oder des Nervensystems ab
Das Diagramm
unterscheidet zwischen skelettmotorischen
Gehirn-
und peripheren Dehnungsreflex-
Controllern und zwischen sensorischen Zustandsschätzern
Gehirn und Peripherie  Alle Sinnesorgane Sinnesoberflächen Sinnesoberflächen
Das Diagramm zeigt eine technische
Perspektive, die
wichtig zu beachten ist, dass bei einem psychologischen
Experiment, bei dem der Experimentator
den Teilnehmern eine Verhaltensaufgabe vorschreibt,
so dass es eine Externalität gibt
und das Gehirn eines Teilnehmers dann als
Kontrollsystem fungiert, um das Verhalten zu erreichen
Das vorgeschriebene Verhalten
Systeme, die den Körper aufrechterhalten,
dienen also Systemen, die den Körper bewegen,
die wiederum einem vorgeschriebenen Verhalten dienen.
Konzentrieren Sie sich also wieder auf das
Vorschreiben, die Externalität, die
Informationen, die in
Ordnung kommen,
Funktion des Laptops. Ja, als nächstes ein
Funktionsblockdiagramm für eine steuerungstheoretische
Sicht  der Allostase Im Gegensatz
zu Abbildung 5 zeigt dieses Diagramm ein
Regelsystem mit geschlossenem Regelkreis, das für die
autonome Regulierung des Körpers und
des gewünschten Aufgabenverhaltens des Experimentators ausgelegt ist,
ersetzt durch oder durch den
allostatischen Kapazitätsschätzer,
der Vorhersagen von Kapazitätskurven sendet,
die wir uns bereits angesehen haben
die Innenrezeption  ive State Estimator
und empfängt Vorhersagefehler, mit
denen seine
Schätzungen aktualisiert werden. Die aktualisierten Schätzungen werden als
Referenzsignal an die Motorsteuerung des Besuchers ausgegeben.
Dieses Diagramm zeigt eine formale
logische Struktur
aber die Kästchen und Pfeile bilden
keine
Wiederholung ab, bilden sie nicht eins zu eins auf die
Anatomie des Gehirns oder des Nervensystems ab, in
Ordnung,
großartig,
um nur den Unterschied hier hervorzuheben, ist
die linke Seite fast wie ein
lehrreiches
Arrangement, und so arbeitet der
experimentelle Psychologe  denkt über
diese Aufgabe nach, was so ist, als würden wir
die Anweisungen des Pseudocodes für die
Aufgabe aufschreiben, halten Sie Ihre Herzfrequenz innerhalb dieses
Bereichs,
und dann gibt es einige Entscheidungen
mit dem Skeletor-Motorsystem, ob es
in der Lage ist, bewusst zu handeln
und sich zu dehnen
oder eher unbewusst
und dann durch  Physiologie
im Körper oder in der Außenwelt, die
intercepti  Der fünfte Zustandsschätzer kommt in
Einklang mit der gewünschten
Umsetzung der skelettmotorischen
Entscheidung,
im Gegensatz
dazu wird
in dieser steuerungstheoretischen Sicht die Rolle der Aufgabeninstruktionen sozusagen
durch den allostatischen Kapazitätsschätzer
als Imperativ ersetzt, der sich
durch ein sehr ähnliches Set speist  auf der rechten
Seite, aber hier haben wir tatsächlich den
Entscheidungscontroller für Eingeweidemotoren
im Gegensatz zu einem
Entscheidungscontroller für Skalarmotoren, da dieser sich mehr darauf
konzentriert, wie
die linke Taste oder die rechte
Taste zu wählen, und Abbildung sechs sich mehr auf
die Art des Laufs konzentriert
Reflexkontrolle Theoretische Sicht, aber das
verallgemeinert Jenseits
okay Ich denke, das ist nur eine weitere Sicht
Abschnitt 4 Allostase als Flugbahnverfolgung
Stochastische optimale Kontrolle
Dieser Abschnitt wird unser formales
Modell der allostatischen Entscheidungsfindung beschreiben Der
allostatische Pfad Integrale Kontrolle Apic-
Modell
Apic hat eine einfache Idee  Kern ebenso
wie Wahrnehmungskonzepte dienen als innere
Modelle des Bo  Die Aktionskonzepte der sensorischen Oberflächen von
dy dienen auch als interne
Modelle potenzieller Verhaltensweisen und ihrer
vorhergesagten Ergebnisse.
Abschnitt 4.1 treibt eine SOC-
Zielfunktion aus der mathematischen
Form an, durch die Abschnitt 2
Leistungskurven darstellte,
dann werden Abschnitt 4.2, 4.3 und 4.4
beschrieben, um dieses apische Modell
zu spülen  fügen Sie
nein hinzu, gehen wir dorthin, alles in Ordnung 4.1
Umwandeln von Kapazitätskurven in
objektive Funktionen,
da jede gegebene Kapazitätskurve wie
die 1 und Abbildung 1 oben,
die ein Maximalwert auf der vertikalen
Achse ist, durch ihren maximalen y-Wert geteilt werden
kann, um sie auf den Bereich zu normalisieren  zwischen 0
und 1. Einmal auf diese Weise normalisiert,
kann es als kumulative
Verteilungsfunktion aus der Wahrscheinlichkeitstheorie interpretiert werden.
Dies ist genau das, was
Srinivasan Laughlin und Dubs
getan haben, um das Feuern von
Netzhautneuronen und Fliegen als eine Form der
prädiktiven Codierung zu interpretieren  in Abbildung 1
ergibt die Ableitung einer kumulativen CDF-Verteilungsfunktion eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit  Dichtefunktion PDF,
sodass die Ableitung einer CDF eine PDF ergibt,
ist dies die gebräuchlichere
Art, eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung darzustellen,
bei der die Höhe auf der vertikalen Achse
der Wahrscheinlichkeit in der PDF entspricht,
aber für eine PDF, die von einer Kapazitätskurve
abgeleitet wird, die relative
Reaktionsfähigkeit darstellt  zur Störung nennen wir eine
solche Verteilung eine Referenzverteilung
,
also ist dies eine Transformation
statistischer Verteilungen zwischen der
PDF, die die Wahrscheinlichkeitsdichtefunktion ist
, und der kumulativen CDF-Verteilungsfunktion.
Sie könnte einigen sehr vertraut sein,
für einige könnte sie völlig neu sein, also ist
alles gut  hoffentlich ist dies immer noch nützlich
, um die Beziehung zwischen den
beiden zu betrachten,
also hier auf der linken Seite dieser drei
Bilder das PDF, das die
gebräuchlichere Art ist, eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung darzustellen.
Wir würden sagen,
dies ist eine gleichmäßige Verteilung, für die eine
Wahrscheinlichkeit von eins zu sechs besteht  jedes
Ergebnis aus einem sechsseitigen Würfel
oder in einer
Situation mit einer Gaußschen Glockenkurve, die  h Diese beiden mittleren
und rechten Bilder zeigen
das PDF der Glockenkurve ist die
Glockenkurve, also ist das PDF das bekannteste.
Die gleichmäßige Verteilung ist wie eine
flache Linie im PDF. Die Glockenkurve ist
wie eine Glockenkurve im PDF
Da Sie jedoch die Maximal- und
Minimalwerte kennen,
wenn auch nur
asymptotisch, können Sie eine kumulative
Verteilungsfunktion erstellen, die im
Grunde so niedrig beginnt, wie die Funktion
die Unterstützung für diese Verteilung erreichen kann, und sich
nur kumulativ ansammelt,
sodass es nützlich ist, die
Frage zu beantworten was ist  die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, vier oder drei oder zwei oder eins zu erhalten
, das sind zwei Drittel, oder wie hoch ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit, einen z-Wert von
unter zwei zu erhalten, wie zwei Standardabweichungen
positiv, welcher Bruchteil der Kurve
unter diesem z-Wert im PDF liegt  und das
ist ansprechbar, indem schnell nur
ein Punkt auf dieser CDF nachgeschlagen wird,
es stellt sich heraus, dass die Beziehung
zwischen dem PDF und der CDF, die
vertrauter ist, wieder wie Würfeln
oder Bewerten gefällt  Die Höhe in einem
Klassenzimmer
kann
auf der zuvor besprochenen Kapazitätskurve verwendet werden
, um zu einer Verteilung zu gelangen, die sich bei
Maximierung an dieser
Stelle der maximalen Kontrolle befindet,
sodass hier die CDF von Abbildung 2
die Ableitung erhält und dann
die PDF
mit dieser Art von Negativ wird
Kurvenform und das wurde
irgendwie angedeutet, als diese orangefarbene
Linie maximiert wurde. Die orangefarbene Linie, die
maximiert wurde,
ist der Höhepunkt dieser
Glockenkurve, aber es ist kein klassischer
Klettverschluss, sondern ein Berg, es ist ein
Gipfel, von dem Sie wissen, auf welcher Seite  Sie sind
eingeschaltet und daher ziemlich einfach in
Richtung
ähm
zu optimieren. Aus Gründen der analytischen Bequemlichkeit übernehmen wir die
Praxis von tedorov 2006, eine
logarithmische Dichte zu verwenden, den Logarithmus einer PDF als
objektive Funktion und nicht die PDF
selbst.
Der Arbeitspunkt
erscheint dann weiterhin als lokales Maximum  Während der
Gewinn die Kosten der Bewegung weg
vom Arbeitspunkt und den Wert
der Bewegung darauf bestimmt, zeigt Abbildung 8
die Zielfunktion log de  nsity
entspricht der ursprünglichen Barrel
Reflex Kapazitätskurve
Abbildung 9 verdeutlicht die
Beziehung zwischen den verschiedenen Formen
der Kapazitätskurve weiter, indem alle drei
nebeneinander dargestellt werden, so dass dies eine wirklich
schöne Abbildung ist. Oben links in der
Abbildung ist die Abbildung mit dem Reflex
das hoch- oder heruntergewählt wird,
um den Blutdruck zu regulieren
, das als CDF interpretiert wird,
kann zu einem PDF führen,
und das ist ein einzelner Peak, den Sie
maximieren können,
anstatt zu versuchen, einen Rest zu berechnen,
die Form dieser Kurve wird etwas
schöner, um sie rechnerisch zu optimieren
Wenn Sie es so machen, dass es wie eine
glattere Schüssel ist
und nicht wie eine umgekehrte
Trichterform,
können wir nur
näher darauf eingehen, warum ich denke,
dass das cool sein wird, warum ist dieser Protokollschritt
wichtig oder ist er wichtig, aber ausreichend zu
sagen  dass dies der große Zug ist, der es
Ihnen ermöglicht, den Sigmoid-
Jonglierakt in
die Bergbesteigung zu verwandeln
Wir behaupten nicht, dass unser grafisches Modell
die Anatomie des Gehirns genau erfasst.
Es erfasst die referenzbasierte
sensorische Motorsteuerung über eine Hierarchie
von Zeitskalen. Ein einzelnes Merkmal, das
mit einem Gehirn geteilt
wird  besprechen Sie es in Punkt 1.2,
Abschnitt 4.2. Es wird auch nett sein, darüber zu diskutieren, dass
es eine optimale Nahrungssuche ist. Die Theorie schlägt eine
funktionelle Form für die allostatische Kontrolle vor.
Wollen Sie etwas im Voraus
über eine optimale Nahrungssuche hinzufügen?
Ich möchte
mit den Autoren sprechen  Was bedeutet das
überhaupt,
das wird großartig, in Ordnung, Gleichung
acht.
Globale Erfassungsrate
Abschnitt 4.3 Feedback oder Feed-Forward-
Steuerung mit generativen Aktionskonzepten.
Hier sind also einige weitere Formalismen, und dies
gehört nicht zum experimentellen
psychologischen Rahmen,
sondern eher zum steuerungstheoretischen
Rahmen  der allostatische Kapazitätsschätzer
im linken
Abschnitt 4.3
Gleichung 10 Gleichung 11.
weitere Variablen
stoc  hastic optimale Steuerung SOC, die bereits
erwähnt wurde
Gleichung 12.
Abbildung 10. hier wird es schön sein,
ein hierarchisches generatives Modell zu diskutieren
, das mehrere Zeitskalen und
Referenzverteilungen auf jeder Ebene erfasst,
ohne empirische Fragen
zu neuronalen Hierarchien zu beantworten. Hier verwenden wir
ein Modell mit L gleich  Vier Modelle, die zu
Abbildung Sechs passen.
Sie definieren, was einige dieser Knoten bedeuten,
aber die Y-Achse erhöht die Zeitskala,
also vielleicht langsamere Dinge weiter oben und
dann rechts ist der Zeitverlauf,
also was bringt Sie dazu, darüber nachzudenken
oder was ist  So können wir uns
der Interpretation dieser
gut nähern. Ich versuche nicht, ein kluger Apple zu sein,
aber ich finde es interessant, dass L4
Ihnen ziemlich viele
Informationen gibt, die ich meine, es gibt
vielleicht und sie reden darüber  Tatsache,
dass es mehr als vier Ebenen gibt, aber
sie wollen sich für mich auf diese konzentrieren. Ich
meine, wohin mein Gehirn geht, ist in Ordnung, also haben
wir das Wasser, wir haben die Hefe,
wir haben den Hopfen, wir  Ich habe die Körner und
das kann ein ziemliches Produkt erzeugen,
also können Sie darüber hinweggehen,
dass Sie Saft oder was auch immer hinzufügen können, aber
Sie haben die vier Grundzutaten, also bewegen Sie sich
jetzt durch die Zeit, was das
ermöglicht, also wäre es wieder schön für sie
um das auseinander zu ziehen, denn ich
denke, selbst darin gibt es genug,
um
eine Menge Dinge
richtig zu verstehen. 4.4 Feedback-Steuerung mit
generativen Aktionskonzepten. Es gibt
immer noch Gleichung 13, Gleichung 14. und dann ein
nettes Zitat Leser, die mit
Vorhersageverarbeitung vertraut
und aktiv sind  Inferenz erkennt die
Form der obigen Gleichung 14.
als negative freie Energie oder Variationsuntergrenze.
Zur Diskussion siehe einige
Zitate, da Ziele
typischerweise auf
mehrere äquivalente Weisen ausgeschrieben und interpretiert werden können, von denen
jede ihre eigenen Intuitionen haben kann. Es
gibt Argumente  für die rechnerische und
thermodynamische Effizienz der Minimierung
dieser spezifischen Divergenz im Verlauf
der neuronalen Verarbeitung, aber bis heute die
avai  Etikettenbeweise schließen andere komplexere Informationsdivergenzen nicht aus,
um die Feedback-
Korrektur von Bewegungen zu bestrafen,
daher ist es ziemlich interessant, wie unterschiedliche
Untergrenzen Variationsuntergrenzen negative freie
Energien existieren, als gäbe es erwartete
freie Energie und dann gibt es freie
Energie der erwarteten Zukunft und es gibt alles
von  Diese Varianten und dann jede dieser
Energien kann anders zerlegt werden
wie Gleichung 2.6 im Lehrbuch,
also ist es
interessant zu sehen, wie sie zunächst
zu dieser Art von Überfluss konvergiert haben
und warum sollte es eine solche Resonanz
mit dem Prinzip der freien Energie haben
und was tut es  das bedeutet,
und wie können dann unterschiedliche
Aufteilungen dieser Energiegrenzen uns dabei helfen,
über Systeme nachzudenken, die überleben.
Ich füge hier einfach hinzu, Daniel, dass
wir zu diesen Dingen kommen werden, aber bis zu
diesem Punkt in der Arbeit hatte ich wohl ein
wenig Zeit  der Vertrautheit und ich hatte nicht wirklich
mit der Art von Gleichschritt zu kämpfen, mit der
sie das durchmachten,
aber  Sobald wir bei Gleichung 13
und dem Sprung zu Gleichung 15 und 16
angelangt sind, muss jemand, der klüger ist als
ich, in der Lage sein, diesen
Sprung in wirklich einfachen Worten zu erklären, denn
obwohl ich ihn einige Male gelesen habe
Ich bin mir immer noch nicht ganz sicher, wie es
funktioniert, also werden die Autoren wirklich
ihre ihre ihre weichsten Handschuhe mitbringen wollen,
weil ich meinen
Handheld
brauche. Ja, stimmte zu
Fancy
J
Gleichung 14.
und der analytische Ausdruck für den
optimalen Rückkopplungsregler allein
Gleichung 15 in die Bellman-Gleichung
Gleichung 12 würde
Gleichung 16 ergeben. Lassen Sie uns lernen, was es ist
Term
ergibt ein rechnerisch besser handhabbares
Problem,
das der Divergenzterm in Fancy
J genau so liefert, da er
als genau
der Unterschied geschrieben werden kann  zwischen dem hartnäckigen
harten Maximum unter Q Stern Stern sub Phi
und dem leichter handhabbaren glatten Maximum
unter dem vorgeplanten Aktionskonzept in
Symbolen Gleichung 17. ziemlich interessant
okay
ums Gleichung 17 bis 21
dann der letzte Abschnitt Abschnitt fünf
Diskussion
vielleicht kannst du mir helfen  heute sind wir also 13
bis 17 und dann 18 19 und 20 eine
Möglichkeit,
einige der skalenfreien
Formalismen mit den skalenspezifischen oder
skalenfreundlichen
Details zusammenzufügen, insbesondere wenn Sie dies lesen
, haben Sie sie gesehen  Der Versuch, das zu
klären
, ist eine großartige
Frage,
und Sie sprechen von global,
und ich denke, sie müssen in der Lage sein, das zu
buchstabieren, und ich denke, ja, aber noch
einmal, ich bin, ich bin,
es war ganz plötzlich, dass die Dinge
für mich in den Graben liefen
Hier ist, was ich
wagen würde,
im frühen Abschnitt
gibt es einen Kontrast zwischen
Homöostase und Allostase
und darüber, wie Belohnungssysteme
unter bestimmten
verteilten Modellen der Neuroanatomie des Gehirns
und einer Funktion nicht mehr erforderlich sind
Daher glaube ich, dass die folgenden
Formalismen das erweiterte
Ziel
in ein Optimalitäts- und Optimierungsframework
wie die Bellman-Gleichung einsetzen, die
häufig zur Belohnungsmaximierung verwendet wird. Ich werde also
belohnt, indem ich auf den Gipfel des
Berges
komme, also werde ich Pfade basierend bewerten
davon, wie viel Belohnung sie ansammeln,
und dann wird Neugier oder so weiter im
Laufe der Zeit in dem Maße wertvoll sein, in dem
Horizon meiner
Meinung nach die Belohnung in Bezug auf die Höhe erleichtert,
während wir hier die Entwicklung dahingehend sehen
, wie z.
B. die Maximierung der optimalen Manövrierfähigkeit mit der pdfcdf-Beziehung
Anstatt zu versuchen, die
Divergenz auf den Mittelpunkt des CDF zu reduzieren,
maximieren Sie Ihre Reaktionsfähigkeit
in Bezug auf die Maximierung des Protokoll-PDF. Okay,
also denke ich, dass dies die erweiterte
Um-Belohnungsfunktion
ist, die handhabbar ist,
und dann bleibt noch etwas Arbeit,
um diese Funktion und wie sie zu spezifizieren  verhält sich
vielleicht
okay
dann Abschnitt fünf Gespräch
abfangen stabilisiert Handlung und
baut al auf  Losatische Referenzen
Leute können sich die Zitate ansehen Alles
, was hier zusammenzufassen ist
Nein In Ordnung 5.1 Das Gehirn als einen
allostatischen optimalen Regler zu betrachten
Das allostatische Pfad-Integral-Steuerungs-
Apic-Modell in Abschnitt 4 impliziert eine
Reihe spezifischer Hypothesen Jenseits der
allgemeinen zur stochastischen Optimalen Steuerung
gibt es einige Diskussionen  von gemeinsamen
Modellierungsentscheidungen mit aktiven Inferenzmodellen
, die
vielleicht ausreichen, um apic als
eine Art aktives Inferenzmodell zu betrachten,
und dann ein paar andere Funktionen,
die mit aktiven Inferenzmodellen im
engeren Sinne geteilt werden, falls überhaupt eines existiert,
und auch damit verbundene Modellierungsbemühungen, dem
nichts hinzuzufügen ist
Nein, sie formulieren das ziemlich klar
hier, du willst es nur
richtig durchlesen. 5.1 liefert einige Vorhersagen
und einige Kontraste mit dem Apik-Modell.
5.2
Der Körper und das Gehirn durch die Linse
der Kontrolltheorie.
Abbildung 6 zeigt, wie viszerale Sinnesdaten
effektiv aufsteigen  um X zu werden afferente
abfangende Vorhersagefehler
möchten Sie br erklären  iefly, was ein X-Zufluss
bedeutet,
weil die Leute das vielleicht
im Glossar erklären, aber es ist im
Grunde ein offensichtliches Signal auf einem
Betriebssignal, es gibt ein bisschen
Rekursion,
da möchten Sie dem etwas hinzufügen,
ähm,
ich
sehe die Unterscheidung,
nur um hervorzuheben, was afferent ist  ist
afferent leitet oder leitet
nach innen oder zu etwas für die
Nerven das zentrale Nervensystem für
Blutgefäße das Organ wird richtig versorgt
und ähm,
wie würden Sie genaue Bemühungen unterscheiden,
nur es ist nur so, dass es so
kumulativ ist,
es ist nicht so etwas wie das
Erste
ist, was ich davon weggenommen habe, dass die
Anhäufung dieser offensichtlichen Signale
interessant ist.
Ich glaube, Sie irren sich. Das ist, was ich genommen habe.
Fünf drei Interzeptions- und Kapazitätskurventheorien
der peripheren prädiktiven Codierung
begründen, dass die
metabolisch billigsten Reaktionen eines Neurons
die vorhersagbaren Stimuli darstellen sollten,
während sie teuer sind  Antworten sind
für die überraschendsten Reize
einige Vorhersagen vorbehalten  s und Vorschläge von
Barrett 2017
und Erkenntnissen von Dwark im Jahr 2013, dass bestimmte
periphere Abfangjäger und Menschen
ihre operante Feuerrate
unter einem konstanten Stimulus auf Null reduzieren
, also ist das irgendwie interessant, als ob keine
Änderung
mir davon erzählen würde und das
sollte billig sein darunter  Ein Modell, bei dem sich
etwas seltener als nicht ändert,
und es gibt noch einige weitere
Hypothesen, von denen wir angenommen haben, dass eine
Erhöhung dieser Reaktionsfähigkeit
, die in diesem Apikmodell unerlässlich ist,
als Belohnung wirken könnte,
die Verhaltensverläufe positiv verstärkt,
während eine Abnahme der
Reaktionsfähigkeit als negative Kosten wirken könnte
Verhaltensverläufe verstärken,
sodass Optionen über die
unendliche Zeit offen gehalten werden. Horizont wird
gleichbedeutend damit, das Geschäft am Laufen zu halten oder
die Physiologie begrenzt zu halten,
ja,
ausländische
Kontinuität, anstatt nur die richtige
Menge an USD oder Kalorien zu maximieren,
sondern eher eine reduzierte oder
begrenzte Überraschung über eine Reichweite und eine
Flugbahn zu haben und  eine Strategie
nicht  In diesem Modell, wie hier angegeben
, um diese
5.3 Abfang- und Kapazitätskurven zu generieren,
mehr
5.4 Schlussfolgerungen. Schließlich kehren wir zum
Amateur-
Völkerballspieler zurück,
der Ameise, ja und
ähm, einige Zusammenfassungen des Apik-Modells
und Vorschläge zu seiner Kompatibilität
mit einer Bezugskontrollhypothese
und einigen davon  seine Handhabbarkeit
das ist die Diskussion dann Anhang B
Klimaanlage,
über die wir zuvor gesprochen haben, aber es ist
ein ziemlich cooles Thema, also überspringen Sie
einfach diese Anhänge und diskutieren
sie mit den Autoren. Wir hoffen, dass dann
einige weitere Gleichungen in Gleichung B
formuliert werden Rezept und  Kontrolle
führt aerodisch zum Prinzip der freien Energie
fep
mehr von Anhang B Anhang C apic Modellableitung
Details
Gleichungen
C 0.1.2 vollständige Ableitung der
Optimalwertfunktion und Übergangsdynamik weitere
Gleichungen
Die Pfadintegralform für die
Werterwünschtheitsfunktion gibt
der Technik ihren Namen  der Wegintegralsteuerung
und so weiter eine Art Schlussbemerkung
wir  fragte sich, wie dies mit der
Bayes'schen Mechanik
und der Pfadformulierung der ganz
rechten der drei
Seiten der Bayes'schen Mechanik zusammenhängt
und wie möglicherweise aus einem
ganz anderen Ausgangspunkt
und mit unterschiedlichen
Ansätzen und Einschränkungen
einige ähnliche Merkmale
entstanden und
in apic hervorgehoben wurden
die auch
in der Pfadformalisierung hervorgehoben und für die Bayes'sche Mechanik relevant sind
, und vielleicht gibt es dort so etwas wie
eine Art nicht zugeordnetes Venn-
Diagramm und einige Ähnlichkeiten und
Unterschiede. Die
Nähe zum letzten Livestream,
ob zufällig oder absichtlich,
macht das
äh so, wie Sie es betrachten  Dieses Papier ist
interessant, ich sage nur,
ja
stimmte zu,
alles, was Sie abschließen möchten.
Ich denke, die Idee, in der Lage zu sein,
sich einen Mod bei der Modellierung und der internen
Modellierung und der Art der Koordination davon anzusehen
, entweder
wieder irgendwie als mindestens zwei  andere
als Risikomanagement- oder
Risikominimierungsübung, also eine Begrenzungsstrategie
oder als Option gen  Es
wäre
wirklich interessant, mit den Autoren darüber zu sprechen
, ob
das Apic-Modell in beiden Bereichen funktioniert oder nicht,
bis ich den Sprung zwischen
Formalismus 13
und allem überwunden habe  den Weg nach oben zu 17 18 19 bis 20.
Aber ich meine, mit einer Erklärung dafür
und äh und und einem sanften Stoß wäre es
interessant herauszufinden,
wie das funktioniert, wenn diese Dinge
anscheinend wir als physiologische
Einheiten sind  Ich bin in der Lage, sowohl das
Risikomanagement als auch die
Erweiterung der Optionsgeneratoroption zu jonglieren, also bin ich
wirklich ziemlich aufgeregt darüber, dass
ich von hier aus das Gefühl habe, wie soll
ich das in Bezug auf das lesen, was ich kann, wie
weit ich es bringen kann  Nächste Wette
aus allostatischer Sicht Ich denke
, das ist
wirklich aufregend, wenn Sie, wie ich schon sagte, wenn
ich
ein besseres Gefühl dafür bekommen kann, wie dieser Sprung in
ihrem Modell funktioniert
[Musik],
ja, definitiv interessiert an diesem
unendlichen Zeithorizont und dieser Mentalität
von wie
w  Das ist die beste physiologische
Entscheidung über den unendlichen Horizont.
Warten Sie, das ist eine großartige Frage, und ja,
das Ewige, jetzt
die Präsenz
und dann ähm auch nur ein bisschen
banaler, wie z. B. welche Art von Daten
für diese Art von Modell relevant sind,
sind es Daten, für die es bereits existiert
Leute,
ist es etwas, bei dem Sie
viel aus einem spärlichen Datensatz extrapolieren können,
oder benötigen Sie eine Reihe von Replikation,
um ein gutes statistisches Vertrauen in den
Modellparameter zu erhalten und Ergebnisse zu extrahieren
, die nicht trivial sind,
und wo wird diese
Technologie oder dieser Ansatz verwendet?  oder
wo könnte es verwendet werden, es gibt so
viele Dinge, über die es interessant sein wird,
darüber zu sprechen.
Danke für all die Vorbereitung und
Hilfe bei diesem Dean und bis zum
Punkt eins und darüber hinaus. In Ordnung, mein Freund
, pass auf dich auf